Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question de Lily
et c'est une question qui est excellente
parce qu'elle parle des aînés :
« Y a-t-il des résidences ou des centres de soins
où l'on respect que les valeurs
et les cultures des aînés autochtones? »
Merci Lilly pour cette question parce que
c'est une question à la base même de notre société.
La place des aînés.
Souvent, j'ai eu des chocs quand je voyais comment
on traitait les aînés dans la société nord-américaine.
Que ce soit au Québec
ou aux États-Unis,
le fait de mettre des aînés tous ensembles
dans des centres isolé du reste
de la communauté, ou même qu'on les ignore,
qu'on ne les visite pas, c'est très contraire
à ce que moi j'ai vu en grandissant,
où l'aîné est au centre de la vie culturelle,
au centre aussi
de la vie familiale.
On va habiter avec notre grand-mère
ou avec notre grand-père, on va faire
en sorte que les aînés soient transportés
de chez eux à l'événement social
qui se passe dans la communauté.
Ils vont même avoir priorité pour aller
manger lors de festins, lors de mariages.
L'aîné est très central.
Mais je comprends aussi que quand on parle de CHSLD, on parle de soins de longue durée,
on parle de soins spécialisés et oui,
dans ce cas-ci, il y a des systèmes
qui sont mis en place selon les communautés.
Certaines communautés vont bâtir
des maisons pour les aînés au centre
de la communauté pour que les aînés puissent
voir les jeunes, la vie, passer autour d'eux.
Des fois, malheureusement,
on a aussi peu d'accès à des soins de santé
de longue durée et les aînés doivent être
placés dans des centres plus traditionnels,
comme ceux qu'on a au Québec.
Mais la famille s'arrange
pour visiter très souvent. Les amis vont
visiter souvent, parce qu'on ne veut pas
que l'aîné soit isolé, soit seul.
C'est certain que ce n'est pas un système idéal,
ce n'est pas un système qui permet
de connecter l'aîné
et la génération suivante.
Ce qui fait qu'on a souvent, au Québec
je trouve, une dissonnance entre les aînés
qui veulent protéger leur futur
et les jeunes qui ne pensent pas
à leurs aînés ou ne pensent pas
à l'idée qu'eux-mêmes vont être des aînés.
C'est certain que c'est encore
très central pour nous, mais c'est des fois
des valeurs qui sont très difficiles
à garder en vie vu le manque
de financement dans certaines communautés
de pouvoir créer des projets ou
des lieux qui sont vraiment culturellement
sensibles. Donc, merci beaucoup Lily,
c'est une question qui me tient
énormément à coeur parce que je suis
une aînée en formation. Dans quelques années,
ça va être à mon tour, donc il faut toujours
avoir nos aînés à coeur
et dans notre pensée quotidiennement.
Je vous souhaite une très belle semaine
et  j'espère que vous n'allez pas hésiter
à nous envoyer des questions
et à partager ce vidéo.